ancients is a is a cool thing to do and
i do believe it's important because
there's something that happened and
we're gonna get into this there's
something to happen to the ancients
there's a reason why this it's so
mysterious
and i think that if we don't learn about
that it's just gonna happen again and it
would break my heart for us to have made
it this far technologically for after us
to go back to the dark ages and
and start over again and i fear that
that's possible if we don't learn from
the mistakes of the past so i think
that's a perfect lead into starting to
talk about some of these cycles that
have happened in the history i'm not the
best historian in general but i am
fascinated with so many different things
in life and so i tried to kind of
chronologically put in order some of the
ancient civilizations that
are hot topics of
mystery whether or not they existed or
where it is and what it was all about
and of course the main aspect that is
the most
interesting is the technologies and just
how things were made and and what kind
of technologies they had you know
looking at ancient egypt and being there
and and to see where it's at in the time
frame that it existed and you go like we
couldn't even we'd have a hard time
doing that now you know like there's
things that will be difficult now that
they can't even figure out how to
engineer
so clearly there was different
technology and the question of course is
who who did that technology come from
and um so almost like closing the loop
from the very beginning when we started
talking about stars
is you know one of the things that's so
common such a common thread within so
many of the civilizations is their use
of the stars and especially orion's
belts and the three
the three stars of orion's belt and
those correlating with um with the great
pyramid and the other two um and then
that happens there's lots of there's
lots of other similar situations in
different places in the world so
if we're going back back back like
probably one of the most interesting
things that i think is getting more
more attention
um
more recently is the younger driest
period where you know there was
potentially uh well no there wasn't
potentially there was a cataclysm there
was something that hit earth
a comet an asteroid
something like that and
it
sent the world into
into
extinction essentially and they can even
find like
soot and ash and all kinds of things as
a layer in the soil to confirm this
and
they learn all this through carbon
dating and things like that but the
younger drives period being about what
was it somewhere around 11 to 13 000
years ago so yeah yeah 11 600 is like
the onset is what they say well there
was a couple events and one happened
like 12 800 and then the other twelve
thousand six hundred so like in the
middle of it is the younger driest where
there's this deep cooling
and so like like you said like this is
like this is a this is scientific fact
what you have
is um as validated through uh core eye
samples from um
antarctica and greenland which show that
the earth went through these cycles of
extreme
heating and cooling
rapid thawing of uh or rising of the
global sea levels because of falling of
the ice caps um more than 30 percent of
the entire earth's land mass is covered
in that soot you're talking about
signature traces of a cosmic impact
including nanodiamonds sphericals
melt glass iridium all traits that are
proven to have come from a cosmic impact
in fact
they even say that at the same period of
time there was global fires lot they
think larger than even the uh during the
impact event that uh uh was said to have
wiped out the dinosaurs and and it's
like and then with that came uh
a extinction level event this is just
north america uh that i'm about to cite
but 75 of all mammals in north america
went extinct at that same period of time
um and they found like there's evidence
of a cataclysm they found woolly
mammoths with food in their mouths and
they're like knocked over and frozen
with their legs broken like something
poof them over a woolly mammoth
bunch of them too and it's like
something happened and the evidence is
there
and some people say this is like the
biblical legends of a flood that the
earth's sea levels rose
x amount of feet in a relatively short
period of time
most people lived on or near the coast
and it was like essentially a reset for
whatever was going on before that it was
just
epic
hell on earth yeah
obviously um and the way that that plays
into it is kind of in some of the the
next
information which i know you've talked a
lot about which is atlantis and whether
or not the
disappearance
or the extinction
the the the sinking not the sinking the
covering up of atlantis happened at that
time when you came out of the younger
driest and the ice caps melted and then
you know things were flooded so but i'm
wondering as far as like time timeline
goes where do like because i was looking
stuff up because i was curious too i'm
like man how does this all fall in
because i thought of all the things that
i'm kind of curious about so i thought
about the on the anunnaki i thought
about sumerians egyptians mine culture
roman culture uh and atlantis and so
like that's actually the order in which
they came out as far as the order but
that so
where does atlantis come next in the
timeline or is it more
because or is it the anunnaki like do
can we talk about the anunnaki yeah
let's do that they were
i'm gonna make a video on this there are
some that believe that the survivors of
atlantis so if anyone listening that
hasn't heard this like atlantis isn't
just a disney movie it is a legend that
comes from the egyptians and they
discuss how and this is like 2600 bc and
if they said 9 000 years earlier there
was an event that caused the destruction
of this advanced civilization or by
advance like people should consider
relatively means that they were more
advanced than what people thought like
it doesn't mean they're more advanced
than 2022.
um but anyway and
the the the date on that is precise to
the younger driest so to me i'm like
it's scientific evidence that there was
a civilization that got obliterated
because it's like it's too much of a
what a coincidence is that there's some
evidence that would suggest the
survivors of atlantis essentially went
and repopulated because they talk about
these seven sages so this is where
things get wild because i remember
looking into the story of atlantis that
came from plato he got from solon and
and he talks about like so long being
the wisest of the seven sages but it
turns out the sumerians had their own
seven sages and the sumerians are what
we believe to be
the one of the oldest cultures or
civilizations that we have proof of
that's so according to the academics or
so yes that's the
that is the first known documented human
civilization um however we know and that
was before that about what year six
thousand six thousand years ago okay so
about four thousand bc yeah yeah
precisely and
so and what's so wild in you talking
about annunaki so to anyone not familiar
it's like some people suggest that
beings came from other worlds and
created us and gave us knowledge and
everything else and what's so wild about
it is that if you look at some of the
earliest tablets with the sumerian
tablets
some of those i wish i could show you a
photo right now but they show like
these beings on like this bird-like
craft
sitting on it and people looking up at
them holding their hands up and i'm like
are they trying to like show us
you know is it like an alien spacecraft
so to speak and it's like there's some
weird stuff and they have this tablet
showing which some i think is the solar
system um
so it's like
yeah i mean this is taboo this is
conspiracy to some people they're done
of course we're not aliens all right
it's like but i'm like in my back of my
mind i think it's very possible because
i think humans are a very
weird species i think we're
i'll just say i think we're half alien i
think that something came here and
tampered with us and here we are people
think i'm wrong and crazy fine whatever
i don't care i bet you it's true i can't
prove it that's so funny i i just posted
a story about the fact that they just
hired
24 i think nasa maybe hired 24
theologians to study how the humans
would respond to aliens
an alien encounter and my friend sent me
a message back and she was like she was
like we all already know it just let
everyone know you're an alien
that you are but yeah
you know skipping ahead for a second to
egypt i mean it's all temples
it's all temples like there's yes there
are pyramids but they're completely
undecorated there's nothing they're just
i mean we'll talk about it when we get
there but the temples are like there are
so many of them and um and i you know we
will talk about what we think they were
but it just shows how much um commitment
and dedication to a spiritual practice
that they had that they would have so
many temples where so where do we follow
them with like anunnaki sumerians
atlanteans and and that whole dynamic
like what order did they come in and
then what led to the next thing well
that's a good question i think let me
just say so i do
first of all think that we're like this
hybrid species and if that's true i
think it happened a really long time ago
but i don't know what that means i don't
know if that means hundreds of thousands
of years ago a million i really don't
know i had this feeling because we're
such this weird species we don't seem to
assimilate in our environment whatsoever
we look like a if you look at a city
from space it looks like a cancer spot
like we don't we
we need shoes just to go outside and
stuff like we can't even do anything
like we're this weird and we we're just
i don't know with this weird species
that destroys ourselves and
so like to answer your question i don't
know when that if that's true if that's
the case if you're like this hybrid
species and i don't even uh dismiss um
evolution i think there's evidence of
like things are always evolving and
adapting things are always in a state of
change so i don't disagree with it i
just think there's more to the story but
so to answer your question i would say
that something happened
and then
maybe the sumerians or whatever we're
trying to
explain that but it's hard to say um
all i know is that the sumerians came
you know they were around 1500 years
before the egyptians so-called egyptians
started doing the spectacular things
like
the most impressive pyramids say the
pyramids of giza whether it's atlanteans
uh way before them because it's worth
mentioning a lot of people aren't aware
that the egyptians themselves same say
and this is uh inscribed on
the temple of horus i believe
where they
say that the
came from the island of the
primeval ones that had uh survived a
cataclysm
and they repopulated down in egypt and
this kind of coincides with what i'm
researching now as far as the sumerians
talking about seven sages and that the
theory is that
people who survived that maybe this
pretended atlantis existed and they were
relatively advanced doing cool stuff
some people survived if they got
obliterated by the cataclysm and they
went around to different places to
repopulate spread the knowledge i don't
rebuild yeah and
um so i think that there's truth to that
i i that would be my best bet the
atlanteans is proposed that that that it
that it flooded and that
some of those atlanteans you know were
able to survive
and
repopulated in egypt then um on the nile
and that's where the the the story
continued it became from there on out it
was thousands you know or whatever
you're going to tell me how many years
later that you know that it became a
metropolitan and um
and became what it is as what we would
know it today but um but the sumerians
were um
you know a part of that as well
[Music]